Thank you guys for coming to watch me make cupcakes.
I was like love for this to be interactive and really laid back.
So if anybody has any questions or wants me to talk about something specific,
like you could blurt it out or you could like,
hey,
hey or whatever.
Are you the microphone?
Um,
we're going to do two things together today.
First I'm going to make three of our seven limited edition Valentine's Day
flavors would you have here,
which I highly recommend getting.
Obviously I'm Melissa from baked by Melissa and I want you to purchase our
product that I worked so hard to create,
but also our Valentine's Day collection are some of the best flavors we've ever
had before and it's our busiest time of year and I'm just like most proud of
these so I highly recommend them.
Also the packaging is beautiful.
Have this love letter,
gift box.
I'm sorry I have to,
I'm so proud.
It's like it's my child.
Just a little fun fact is that I used to work at Deutsch advertising,
which had its office on the 14th floor and my cubicle was like there and I was
fired from my job there and that's ultimately what got me baking.
Or I was baking,
but like starting baked by Melissa.
So this is super cool and full circle and I'm very honored to be here.
MMM.
And I'm
pregnant.
It's not cupcakes.
Okay.
Anyway,
so I'm going to be three flavors.
The first flavor is my absolute favorite flavor.
It's our dark chocolate cupcake.
I love dark chocolate.
I eat a piece of dark chocolate every night before I go to sleep.
Now I'm just going to pop one of these.
It's so weird that we've never done this before cause it's so simple.
And if you've ever been curious as to how we make the cupcakes now you'll see
and you could totally apply this at home.
If you feel like stuffing your own cupcakes.
Oh,
probably be a little bit bigger.
And we start selling the pan.
But in order to stuff a cupcake,
all you have to do is put your icing or filling in a pastry bag and puncture the
cupcake and just like squeeze.
It's so simple.
I actually used to,
um,
when we first started the company,
I'm not like opera.
I mean now I'm pretty operational,
but um,
I used to use a knife to cut a hole in every cupcake and then stuff it and then,
um,
a few years ago I realize you could just do this,
you know,
they sell like those things that like the course for the crab cakes.
This is a dark chocolate ganache and this is our each dark chocolate icing.
If you happen to have cakes by Melissa my cookbook or get wine,
there was a chocolate icing recipe.
If you switch out the Hershey's cocoa powder for the Hershey's dark cocoa
powder,
you'll get a dark chocolate icing.
And it's so good.
Have you guys tried this one?
It was the ones,
uh,
topped with mini chocolate chips in the pink and red nonpareils.
Really good.
It's so good.
Um,
and then after we do these three flavors,
the next flavor is going to be cookies in milk,
which is like a vanilla version of cookie dough.
And it's also made with a chips Ahoy cookie icing.
Um,
because like I just really liked dessert and snacks and that's kind of how I
create.
So when I was thinking about doing a cookies and milk flavor,
I knew that needed to have chips or the cookies because when I was drawing up,
like that's the could use in load means to me,
you know,
dipping the chips,
like cookie in the milk and then like letting bubbles come up and still got
soggy.
Oh my God,
I'm lying.
I'm not drink milk.
I'm doing,
um,
salted Caramel Pretzel,
which I think we call white chocolate white chocolate pretzel.
So this one's good too.
MMM.
It's all dates alleged,
Jay.
And the icing is actually okay.
But like here,
it's a perfect example.
The icing is a pretzel ice.
So I wanted,
uh,
to figure out a way to do like a salty,
sweet type of cupcake without just doing something basic like salted caramel.
And so I decided to put pretzels in the icing and the brittle.
So this is like white chocolate mixed with ground pretzels.
And then you tried it.
I hope you liked it,
but it's salty and sweet.
And to me it tastes like pretzels and caramel and it's amazing.
So I'm just gonna Finish icing these and top them and then we'll do the last
flavor.
And then after that I am going to make a layer cake for you guys.
Can you talk about,
do you still come up with all the new flavors yourself or do you have a team or
how involved are you still in that?
Awesome.
That's a great question.
I'm very much involved in that process.
I create and conceptualize every new flavor and products that we create.
I'm sorry,
I like,
I'm a little add.
I get out of breath randomly.
Sometimes it's like new.
I think it's because of that.
Um,
but I saw,
I apologize.
Um,
okay.
What happens is I,
so I actually,
I met my husband the day we opened our very first store.
It's a great,
crazy story of how we started the,
he is part of it and they wound up hiring him and the two of us used to ice
every single cupcake together.
Uh,
like the first two years that we were in business.
And then now he works in the bakery and I'm in corporate and my role is
president and chief product officer.
So I create and conceptualize everything,
but then he brings it to production.
So we kind of worked together.
So like I'll be like make a pretzel icing and he'll be like,
or this brittle for example,
like you have to be able to produce it to make thousands of them.
So sometimes in my requests are a little silly,
but he always figures that way,
ways to make them work.
Um,
and sometimes even takes what I've either created once or I'm asking for.
It makes it even better.
It's a very fortunate partnership.
The last of the three flavors that I am making is chocolate cookie dough.
So cookie dough and cookies,
flavors in general are like a very popular thing for us.
Like everyone loves them.
So this is like a chocolate version of cookie dough.
It is chocolate cake.
The stuffing is a chocolate version of cookie dough,
so it has like cocoa in it and it's like salty and sweet and delicious.
It's ice and vanilla icing and it's topped with um,
cookie dough chocolate cookie dough that is here.
It kind of looks like the poop Emoji,
but there's,
there's a picture as well that we print on top to make it look like it.
It works.
It's crazy.
Um,
but my pink chocolate did it melt so well.
So you're just going to get the,
the cookie topic.
And those are three of the Valentine's safe flavors.
I don't know where my blogs are all here.
So then you literally just like,
I would have put gloves on.
It's just like neater and easily,
but it's not big deal.
And that's the chocolate cookie cupcake.
It gets confusing.
We have cookies and cream.
We have cookie dough,
we have chocolate cookie dough.
If you have a double cookie flavor,
which is coming back soon.
But like these are so good and cookies or cake or even more of music.
Okay.
Does anybody want a freshly cupcake baked by Melissa.
Okay,
so that's part one.
That's just like,
you know why I'm here.
Bite sized cupcakes.
They're really amazing.
I love,
I could ice cupcakes all day long.
I used to for like two years,
that's all I did was ice and bake cupcakes
and I couldn't have happier.
But we grew the business though.
No,
I do a lot of things.
So in October I came out with a book that I wrote,
it's called cakes by Melissa.
And the reason that I felt like I needed to write a book was because I had all
of these recipes if my head that I've been using for baked by Melissa all the
time.
And even though you can't like make bite sized cupcakes,
I really wanted the reader to be able to like think the way I think and like get
creative the way I create.
So I think it achieved that and it kind of takes you through my creative process
of like coming up with these legs,
random flavor profiles,
starting with a very base like vanilla cake as an example.
And then adding one or two ingredients and that the op like that you can make
anything.
If you take your vanilla cake base and replaced the liquid,
which is whole milk with strawberry puree,
you get this like balm strawberry cake.
And it's crazy and it's super simple and people always think that baking is like
crazy and really complicated.
But I don't think it is.
So the cake that I'm going to make for you guys today is the tie dye cake
because that's why we're here.
But like we don't have a ton of time together.
So the cake is already made and my husband made it,
he sent it to us,
but so it's big.
So it sounded like one of our sheet pants from the bakery.
Um,
and I like to make my layer cakes this way because
I don't like the crust.
And like obviously if you in the,
in the book the recipe is for like,
uh,
like a quarter.
She,
um,
because that's normal,
but you know,
we got this one so we,
you wouldn't have as much scrap as I'm going to have.
So don't judge.
And I used the scrap to decorate the cake too,
but you take like six inch or however big you want your cake to be.
Amazon is amazing.
You could get like anything you need on Amazon and you don't have to be a baker.
You could Google recipes,
you could get cakes by Melissa and use those recipes
and order everything you need and then just have a lot of fun.
So I actually didn't know that these things existed until I searched on Amazon
because I wanted to be able to make cakes of all sizes when I was recipe
testing.
So I like to punch out my layers because then it's like the whole cake is
delicious,
you know,
layer one got my vanilla icing.
She's anyone know the three ingredients in vanilla icing,
sugar.
Great,
but sugar,
but I'll extract.
It's not,
it's like so easy.
I actually added a little bit of whole milk to this because when I'm spreading
on cake,
you know how it can get really messy if this just makes it like a much
like smoother consistency and it's much to see.
It's like so easy
sell little icing between each layer.
And I like it.
So before I really,
again,
like I wanted to write a book but I wasn't sure how I would get like the bite
sized cupcakes through and this like book that I knew,
I couldn't like give you recipes for me cause it's impossible to bake them.
And that's when I learned how to make cakes.
Like I had obviously made cakes before,
but I had like never really put together a layer cake.
So I'm telling you like I'm not just saying this like obviously yes,
I work with my hands for a living and I made cupcakes.
But like if I could put together these cakes,
I'm like not the neatest person in the world then anyone can.
So that's layer two.
It's like making a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
and then more of an owl I think.
Does anyone have any other questions?
Like what do you want me to talk about?
So you mentioned that people really go crazy for the cookie flavors.
And so I was just curious what,
um,
things like metrics like that have to do with your flavor development.
Like do you kind of use those metrics to figure out next laborers and how do you
do that but also keep to like what you want your tastes to be?
That's a great question.
So luckily I've found that like,
for the most part,
I mean I'm not a vanilla person.
It's like,
believe it or are the tie dye cupcake is our number one seller.
Like thank goodness it is our signature flavor.
It makes complete sense.
It's great for our brand,
but it's like not by like go to,
it's my daughter's,
she loves it.
Um,
but with that said,
like for the most part,
like I know when a flavor is going to be amazing.
So like the dark chocolate,
like as soon as I tasted and did a happy dance and it's like selling so well
right now.
Um,
we obviously like look at the data every week.
Actually Mondays are dedicated to that sales meetings to go over the previous
week.
And one of the reports we look at is the cupcakes and how they sold all cart
because that's super helpful for me and product development.
And I know that the baked by Melissa customer loves like Vanilla and chocolate
and cookies
and like stoner type like you know,
it's like whole baked by Melissa.
It's like the double cookies like Oreo cookie dough chocolate,
like it's so good.
Um,
and that's like what I like,
so it works,
but I'm always looking to see like what sells the bash.
Like sugar cookie dough.
I like the sugar cookie dough recipe that I kind of just like googled and fell
in love with and like,
you know,
maybe like change a little,
but like really it's just like the standard sugar cookie dough recipe that I was
making for my whole office and they loved it.
I was like,
oh my God,
how can I get this in a cupcake?
And then I developed a sugar cookie dough icing,
which a sugar cookie dough,
but like with an icing consistency.
And everyone freaked out over that.
And I kind of knew that they would because it's like vanilla,
but cookie.
So I get you guys,
you know
your sleep sleeper,
that surprised you cells as well as it does that you did expect.
I guess I,
I like things that are like,
I like double cookie.
So I guess like I was pleasantly surprised to see the tie dye tie dye is going
strong.
Tie Dye has been our most popular flavor for like since we started the company.
And then when the book watched we um,
I created an electric tie dye,
which is like,
just like brighter color tie dye and the two are neck and neck.
And like every week I'm sitting in the conference room and I look at the report,
I'm like,
yeah,
like I kind of root for electric tie dye.
I don't know why.
Like the newer one,
I like the colors,
it's super bright.
So I get that surprise me cause like vanilla.
But like I get it people like
who likes vanilla here?
Like over chocolate,
like chocolate.
So it's like surprising,
right?
But it's also very colorful and I've learned that people eat with their eyes.
So like in order for a flavor of anything to be successful,
it has to be equally as beautiful as delicious.
And it sounds like it's not rocket science,
but like,
you know,
when I look at other products out there or when I go into a bakery or
restaurant,
whenever like you,
you really have to sell with the way it looks and then the taste is like the
other half.
Okay.
So I stacked the cake.
Three layers is what I recommend.
Um,
otherwise it gets very difficult.
A spinny thing is super helpful and like you see like it's not super straight,
no promises but the,
but because you have this spinny thing,
it helps because you could like spin it and then I dunno,
it's crazy.
So there's this thing that we refer to as a crumb coat and so yeah,
this is the crumb coat.
So you do like this thin layer of icing around.
Okay.
You do a thin layer of icing around the cakes burst and that kind of just like
keeps everything neat and together.
And then you go back and you ice it again and you're really supposed to like pop
it in the fridge and let the icing harden and then do another layer.
But I also like to complicate things so
I'm going to put glaze on here.
So like,
and it's really pretty,
you know like the little crumbs because they're colorful.
So um,
but you could like just do a chrome coat on a tie dye cake and leave it if it's
looks like Funfetti.
So Kate's been was that came out in October and I did all of this press and I
work with my husband and you know,
we have this weird competitive nature but it like really works and that's kind
of how we come out with such amazing flavors for baked by Melissa.
And I did like a ton of live segments,
so like,
like this,
but like for CIVC where like you have like a five minute segment and like 30
seconds ice the cake.
And One night we were laying in bed and he was like,
you know,
when you do the cakes on live TV,
you should probably make them look like really symmetrical and nice.
I was like,
you try doing that.
It's so hard.
So I'm trying,
I'm going to try and make this really magical and nice for my husband.
It's an area where we're laying in bed.
I'm going to tell him,
but I mean like,
and I like,
I appreciate it.
I appreciate all feedback.
I think it's super important.
Um,
along those lots he look,
but like it's,
it's,
it's pretty nice so far.
Right?
You just gotta like don't overthink it.
You know,
you're baking to enjoy.
Even I,
that's why I bait.
That's why we're all here because I love to bake.
So when you're baking at home,
she didn't enjoy it and like,
you know,
I associate Valentine's Day with baked goods because
if you don't want to buy cupcakes would just totally cool.
I get it.
You should make something and think of me.
Oh Man,
fun.
I think you'll have a great time.
Do it with your friends or like whomever your kid,
you're okay.
So far so good.
Right?
I think you're actually technically I follow a lot of cake makers on Instagram.
They usually start with the top and every time I watched it I'm like,
oh I should start on the top.
And then I forget.
So
one question that people ask me all the time,
it's like,
like how he started baked by Melissa of course.
And like what did you do differently?
All this stuff.
And like I think one thing that's super important to anyone who wants to be
successful at anything,
can you see the prettiness of like,
there's like little specks of the colors inside.
There's a certain attitude that I think is necessary for success in anything,
especially in starting your own business.
And it's a positive attitude.
And I know that sounds crazy,
but my attitude when I was fired from my job,
so I was literally sitting at this thing
yeah.
In my cube a call and I was called to HR and I thought I was getting a
promotion.
I was fired and I was
true.
Yeah,
I saw that guy.
I really,
whatever,
it doesn't matter.
But like I,
I was like,
anyone who got fired,
I like thought it wasn't my fault and I wanted to like,
yeah,
whatever retaliate.
I said I thought I was through with so unjust.
I went right to my brother's office crying and he said,
go home and start your business.
It's go home bigger cupcakes,
we'll start a business out of it.
And it's not crazy because I love to bake and at the time I,
okay,
I don't have a lot of time left,
but I am going to,
I'm going to finish the story too,
but while I'm doing that,
I'm,
I'm gonna make glaze.
This is the best part of this cake.
I take things too far.
If I mess something up,
I'll like put glaze on it and it'll cover it up.
So I didn't mess this one up,
but I'm going to put glaze on it because it's so fun and glazes.
Very complicated.
This is powdered
sugar and I'm going to add whole mill and that's late and I'm going to use a
spoon.
Okay.
So my brother is an entrepreneur,
like,
like a mad scientist entrepreneur,
like always had new business ideas all the time.
And I love to bake and I always wanted to go into business with him,
start a business with him.
So when he said go home and bake your cupcakes,
I was like great.
Like it's a great idea because I'm really upset and I like to do that and it'll
make me happy.
And at the time I was begging my tie dyed cupcakes
for like everyone and anyone.
If it was your birthday and I loved you and I love a ton of people.
I begged you tie that cupcakes.
And the reason that I did that was a,
because I love to bake be because has anyone ever big something delicious and
giving it to somebody that's feeling like truly that's why I did it.
It was totally thought fish.
I love to bake for people cause it made me feel good and I did it all the time
and I had been known for my tie dye cupcakes.
So when he said to do,
and I was like,
great idea.
I begged for batches of cupcakes the night I was fired,
my tie dye,
cookie dough smores
and peanut butter cup.
I would say those are my four favorite flavors.
And I ran them sending them into work with my best friend's little sister who
was interning at Alyson broad PR.
Anyone heard of Alice?
And she was like a celebrity to me.
I'm not needed in the kitchen.
Um,
a female who started her business,
she was,
I like all women work there,
whatever.
I hope that she would like try the cupcakes herself,
but I didn't even know if she like went to work every day.
And
I mean,
I just need to know,
you know,
but like in the back of my mind,
I was hoping that Alison would see the cupcakes and something amazing could
happen and would,
you know,
that's exactly what happened.
So I sent all these cupcakes into work with Carly
who was interning there.
I'm out of breath again,
I'm sorry.
And um,
pals and saw them.
She had her caterer in the office,
luckily at the time and she was like,
Ben,
look,
these kinds of thinks they're amazing.
You should reach out to her.
So he did.
So I got a call from Alison broad's caterer.
Like the day after I was fired from my job.
He wants it to bring me into his office,
which was his apartment,
his little shady.
Then
I went with it,
uh,
for a tasting.
So I ran back to my brother's office and I was like,
Holy Shit,
I just got a tasting with Alison broad's caterer and he had his own business
like building websites for people.
So it was kind of perfect.
Um,
I said like we have to go and they were like,
we have a business already and he could be a part of it.
I'm splitting it up into two bowls and I'm going to die each one pink and blue
because those are my favorite colors.
Um,
and cause they look beautiful when they combine.
So we were like,
okay,
we need a name and a logo.
I wanted to go in there like I had a business already and he could be a part of
it.
Otherwise,
like what would come from the opportunity that was like my mindset and they have
Brian and Matt were like totally cool with it.
They're like a spoon,
like,
like a soup spoon.
Great.
Aha.
Perfect.
Thank you.
So you don't need complicated stuff.
Um,
so my brother's business partner at the time for music box,
which was the web development company and it was like literally just the two of
them in this little tiny office on 38th and eighth was also our childhood friend
Matt.
So like he knew me very well.
So my brother insisted that the name of the company had a personal tie.
So we liked baked by Melissa.
I really wanted the company to be called baked,
but he insisted that my name was in it,
which I'm sort of thankful about.
And Matt created the logo and it's the same exact liberally head today.
I think I cried when I saw it cause it's like so perfect.
It's so who I am and who our brand is now.
And I mocked up bakery boxes with our logo.
I got like flat pastry boxes from the Clover Deli on 34th and second,
which was right across the street from my apartment at the time.
And I went to the caterer for a tasting.
He loved the cupcakes.
And I did my first event with him less than a week after I was fired.
We made business cards that had my name and my home address and my cell phone
number.
But they were also brands at baked by Melissa.
So they look so legit.
My parents were like,
what is happening?
Like people are just gonna be like knocking on your apartment door.
Literally like suite 27 g I was apartment 27 j um,
and yeah,
so people came and they saw these unbelievable bite sized cupcakes that were so
beautiful and also delicious.
Everyone knew cupcakes,
but they had never seen them bite size,
which is so cute.
And they would take a cupcake,
then they would take a business card and then you would go to big by melissa.com
which Brian and Matt obviously helped me create.
And we founded the company together.
So the three of us worked our butts off to get to where we are today.
Um,
we shot the whole website on my ikea coffee table
with a white bed sheet,
which made the table and the cupcakes using my canon point and shoot camera.
And when people saw the cupcakes,
they went to bake five months that you could purchase a hundred cupcakes or more
to be delivered by me from my apartment using the subway.
I'd like put a big mammals a sticker on a white pizza box.
And that's how we started baked by Melissa.
I did a fence,
I called called caterers.
I took advantage of every opportunity that came my way.
Okay,
please time.
This is just really fun.
So I like tie dye and bright colors,
therefore that the cake is going to be very much like that.
So while we were shooting the book,
I realized that if you alternate colors and glaze
on a cake,
it makes like a tie dye effect
and a beautiful shade of purple.
So that was like 10 years ago,
which is crazy.
So since then we've opened 14 retail locations.
We ship our product nationwide.
So you can send these to anyone baked by melissa.com we'll go la,
can you see the top?
I just want to like,
okay.
Anyway.
And then this is an offset spatula.
This is a baby one and it gives it the hot.
So Freddy,
it'll like start to trip and you could totally control all this stuff based on
how much liquid you put in the glaze.
If you want it to drink more than you put more liquid and you want to cover the
whole cake,
he could do that too.
I just like to have fun with it.
Glaze dries really quickly.
So
we kind of have the
correct,
it's just so pretty.
Okay.
Watch this.
Ready.
And you could
you get,
you get like tie dye?
Yeah,
it's fancy.
I'm very air.
We go,
I guess I could probably make it look prettier.
You know what,
I make little smudges.
Let's see.
Like this is how I create things.
Um,
I just kind of go with it and like the end result is always beautiful no matter
what.
Um,
does anybody have any questions for me while I,
how do you,
how do you mass produce something that seems so individualized?
It's a great question.
So when the book came out,
I see,
oh,
and I who is like,
my CEO is probably my favorite person in the world.
Um,
we were like,
shit,
are people going to want to buy cakes?
Now we're just coming out with a book called cakes by Melissa.
Are they going to like assume that we saw cakes?
So we kind of had to figure that out.
Then you know how to mass produce cakes.
So what we do is we make these sheets,
um,
my husband does,
he makes all of these sheets of tie Dye k and then we have one person who
assembled them.
And like I took a really long,
like it's pretty quick.
Um,
we do sell the tires.
I cake just like this,
um,
at baked by melissa.com you can preorder it.
Uh,
we say four days in advance,
but of course we make suggest a exceptions and ah,
wow.
It's so pretty.
Um,
you can preorder it and then pick up in store only.
it's funny cause Allison brought has been ordering a ton of these cakes and I
just love her so much.
I would do anything for her.
Um,
so I actually hand write happy birthday to him,
whoever she wants,
which we do not do but,
but Al's,
whatever Allison watts Allison gets.
So I do that for her and they are,
they're actually ice.
Like this cake is,
I did this for the first time when we were shooting the book.
Like I didn't plan.
I kind of just do,
I could have never told you about this cake was going to look like before I made
it.
Um,
but the cake that I made while we were shooting the book inspired the cake that
we now sell and it's so beautiful and so delicious and so moist.
Sorry.
Voice.
Okay.
What do you guys think about that word?
You think it's gross.
I mean for baking it makes sense,
but we believe we have like conversations about that word a lot in my line of
work,
like meaning at baked by Melissa.
Like what?
We don't use it in our marketing,
although I kind of fight for it
because it,
because it is our product and then I sprinkle blend and there
there's my tie dye.
Okay.
A few boxes of cupcakes to give away for anybody who has questions
back then.
Everyone should just grab a fork.
Okay,
good.
That's what I would do.
That's not true.
It's like an arts and crafts project that you can eat.
So did you always make like mini cupcakes?
If you ever picked the larger ones are going to beat you.
Decide to that specific.
That's a Greg.
I always banked large cupcakes.
I really love cupcakes.
So I wanted the big ones.
But I also would eat two large cupcakes a day and I knew that if I was starting
a business with a product,
it had to be unique and different in some way.
So we decided to make them just a bite.
This way you could try every flavor without the post dessert filled Chin and
everything's under 50 calories.
But we have like,
it's all like real,
like the best butter,
sugar,
Hershey's,
cocoa,
Hershey's chocolate,
like chips ahoy cookies,
Oreos.
But it's just 50 calories less than that because it's just the bike.
It's like clever.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
Or Ige crumb.
I love all cupcakes.
I have a few questions,
but all of that out of wanting all cupcakes,
living in New York.
Do you have any other besides around any other favorite stops around the city?
I love sprinkles.
Okay.
I do.
I love their strawberry.
Hey,
I really,
I just love it all.
I love all cafes.
I even like Crohn's cupcakes.
There is that it,
I used to get to crumb cupcakes every day from the clover deli.
They didn't say they were problems,
but I know that they were or they were like made by the same people who,
yeah.
Any other questions either mom working out?
Are you talking about
when I first had my daughter,
so she's two now.
I was like,
Oh,
you know,
I just work hard and everything.
Give,
give my all,
which is true.
I do.
And it's hard.
So it's just really hard.
Um,
but I really,
I think it's important to like love what you do every day.
So I'm like,
I love going home to my daughter,
but I also love working.
Like I don't think being a stay at home mom would be for me.
I'm tired a lot and of being pregnant and stuff,
but I'm really happy that I am going to be an example for her.
I'm like,
we can do it.
Anyone can do anything and like women can do and I'm happy to embody that.
And it's hard.
Your husband the first day.
Yes,
sure.
Um,
so it was opening day five,
our very first retail location.
Um,
for those of you who like know the Soho area,
well,
the corner of Broadway and spring street before it was Nike town was a cafe
called cafe bakery and Cafe Barry had this little pickup window that was
attached to it and that was our first retail location,
a bite sides if you will,
pick up window on spring street and the corner of Broadway and it was part of
Cafe Bari.
So opening day,
I'm like freaking out thinking who's going to stop at this hole in the wall?
Buy cupcakes they've never heard of before.
I'm 24 years old.
Literally like got fired from my job seven months prior.
It was just like hustling to like bake cupcakes and try and do it.
I love every day and now we're opening a store.
So I was kind of freaking out.
I didn't have the experience or the competence.
I today I'm sitting at the bar,
um,
we had gotten somebody to work the booth for opening day so I could like chill.
I had baked enough cupcakes.
It was like the first moment I was sitting down in months and David Zee was
sitting next to me at the bar and David z used to have all these shoe stores
named David z throughout Manhattan.
Uh,
his death.
He was Ronnie [inaudible] who founded KIPP.
So like that whole,
like Ronnie used to work for him,
whatever.
And like David was a regular cafe berry.
He came every morning for his coffee and he was there that morning for his
coffee and he's like a cat.
He's like an old,
he's like my dad's age.
And he was like a character,
like takes it too far sometimes though I'd never met him before,
but I knew who he was because he was like well known to me.
And um,
he looks at the bartender who I had also never met before and he says a d who
was this beautiful girl?
And the bartender looked me up and down and he said that's my wife.
And I felt like he was such a jerk,
but that time that my husband
okay.
And then I like hired he,
and they're like,
he's Israeli.
So like he was looking at me and he's like foreign eyes.
Like I'm the most beautiful girl in the world and I totally worked.
Yeah.
I'm just Washington.
Okay.
How did you guys come up with like the pricing model for politics are no
insurance a dollar.
Like I obviously buy your product and I spend that,
but this,
some people say that's too much,
too little.
Like how did you talk to at all?
I'm telling you,
it's definitely not too much because there is so much that goes into every
single one of these cupcakes.
You know,
our cupcakes have been a dollar since the day we started the company,
um,
which is pretty crazy.
Um,
and I don't think as much thought went into it as you would imagine or probably
as should,
we should have,
but in bed,
but they're dollar,
it's very clean.
I think it's nice to be able to just like,
hey,
you know,
$3 for three cupcakes.
And,
um,
that was our pricing model
at the time we started the company at the end of the recession too.
So,
you know,
it was a time when people weren't like going and spending a ton of money on
things.
It's like for $1 you could get something that tastes delicious,
brings you back to your child's head and makes you happy.
Instead of like going and buying jeans and yes,
I'm going to eat it.
You a little awesome,
low sepsis,
believe [inaudible] peanuts.
I would have had more confidence in myself probably.
Um,
because my experience,
I've learned that you can do anything.
Like,
I can do anything.
You can do anything.
It's like a certain attitude and mindset and work ethic and like being
persistent and positive and all that stuff.
That's so cliche and totally true and I wish I knew that the way I know that
today because maybe I would have even I,
you know now like if I set my mind to something,
I know I'm going to achieve it,
which is nice.
Thank you so much for being here.
Thank you.
My question is what is your favorite memory?
Oh,
I have so many.
We've been been been around for 10 years.
I took over Instagram recently,
like in October.
Uh,
like during the launch of the book,
this was another,
you can do anything thing like rod the bug in three months,
which was crazy,
but like I really wanted it to watch for holiday 2017 because that's a great
opportunity for us.
It's like have things to talk about from a brand perspective and I told our CEO
like,
I'm going to take over Instagram and that the only way the launch of the bulb
will be successful is if I do that and I'm going to figure it out and make it
happen.
He's like,
you are like,
I know you are now.
And I was very persistent with like the people,
the one person who I knew there and I wound up taking over Instagram's account,
which is like 270 million followers.
I did an Instagram story and a post on the feed on national dessert guy
and
I'm not one to say something's going to happen before it happens,
but like we had gotten confirmation and like we created the concept beforehand
and I was so excited.
So I like told everybody and they said they're going to post it for,
they're like on the other side of the country and like she's like waiting like,
like you know wasting time.
We were in Bloomingdale's after an event and like it wasn't happening.
I was like freaking out.
And then I was like on the subway underground going to another event in Brooklyn
and then we got out of the subway and I thought that I could cry.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's just like,
that's what it's about.
Like we work,
so I view,
we like,
we work so hard.
So like enjoying those like moments and that was a big moment,
but like all the little moments too,
that's like totally necessary.
We'll get one more question over there.
All right.
Thank you.
Um,
did you ever,
were you,
when you were starting up,
do you ever worry about competition and what did you want being finalists to be?
No,
you give me so much credit.
All I knew is that I had the chance to do what I love every day,
which was bake cupcakes and the in turn eat them.
But that focused,
I was focused on doing,
I took advantage of every opportunity that came my way.
Somebody wants to try the cupcakes,
they got cupcakes.
I would go deliver them no matter I called called catering companies.
I just did all of my,
my,
my mind power was focused on doing everything I could to do what I love every
day because I knew that if I didn't and it didn't happen,
then one day I would look back and think,
Coulda,
woulda,
Shoulda,
and I can,
you just can't live my life that way.
So have the rest of the subway.
I didn't,
I didn't have time to think about.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So
cause they used to show me.